Usually, you know, when we talk about a medical diagnosis, there's this expectation of precision.
It feels like engineering.
Right.
It's very black and white.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, you break your arm, the x-ray shows that dragged white line in the bone, and the doctor
just points at the screen.
Broken or not broken, it's clean, and honestly, it's comforting, you know?
Oh, totally.
We love things to be visible and easily categorized.
We do.
But then you step into the world of neurodevelopment, trauma, and acute mental health crises, and
suddenly that x-ray machine is completely useless.
The diagnostic landscape is just entirely murky.
It really is the absolute definition of diagnostic muddy waters.
Yeah.
I mean, you can't just draw blood to measure someone's level of despair.
Right.
And you definitely can't run a scan to see if they're going to harm themselves or someone
else in the next 24 hours.
You have to rely on behavioral cues, human psychology, and incredibly structured assessment
tools.
And that is exactly where we are heading today.
Welcome to this deep dive into the high stakes, high pressure world of crisis management.
It's a heavy topic, but so important.
It really is.
And our source material today is this rigorous set of notes from a licensing exam prep guide,
specifically, Pass Ready Prep by Keek.
We're looking at their crisis and safety module.
Yeah.
This is the exact material clinical professional study to handle worst case scenarios.
Exactly.
But our mission for this deep dive, for you listening right now, isn't just to help you
pass a therapy exam.
We want to extract the universal framework that professionals use to make literal life
or death decisions without panicking.
Which is incredibly hard to do.
Right.
And the goal is to show you how these underlying principles can actually apply to staying
cool and methodical under any extreme pressure in your own life.
What's fascinating here is that in this specific clinical domain, a wrong answer doesn't just
mean failing a test.
It means someone in real life gets hurt.
Yeah.
The stakes are ultimate.
Exactly.
The exam in real world clinical practice really is designed to test one fundamental thing.
Yeah.
Can you stay calm and think in the correct automatic order when everything around you
is chaotic?
Because our biology is fighting us the whole time, right?
Oh, 100%.
Some biology wants us to panic when we see someone in distress.
Our brains flood with cortisol, the logic centers shut down, and we just react impulsively.
So these notes are essentially a codified system for overriding that biological panic.
Precisely.
Okay.
Let's unpack this because that idea of an automatic order is really the secret sauce
to surviving chaos.
The source material outlines four unbreakable pillars.
Yeah.
And these four rules basically carry the entire crisis category.
If you understand these, you understand the architecture of professional crisis response.
So what's rule number one?
Rule number one is you assess before you act, always.
Rule number two is you choose the least restrictive option that still keeps the person
safe.
List restrictive, all right.
Then rule number three, which kind of runs quietly underneath everything, is you document
every single step.
And rule number four is when you are unsure, you consult.
Assess least restrictive option, document, and consult.
That reminds me so much of emergency room triage.
Oh, that's a great comparison.
Right.
Like when someone bursts through the doors of an ER with a major trauma, doctors don't
just start performing surgery the second they see blood.
They have an automatic, unshakable order of operations.
Airway, breathing, circulation.
Exactly.
They follow the protocol so that human panic doesn't override logic.
The phrase the source material uses is perfect.
Automatic beats clever.
I love that phrase.
Because when you are in a crisis, you don't want to try to be a creative genius.
You want a system.
Yeah, you really do.
Because like we said, when you're flooded with adrenaline, your prefrontal cortex,
the logical planning part of your brain just goes offline.
You have to revert to your training.
Which is why this applies to everyone, not just therapists.
Simply.
I want to point out to you listening that these four pillars are a masterclass in objective
decision making during any crisis.
Like a PR disaster or a financial crisis at work.
Yes.
Think about a massive financial emergency.
Our instinct is to immediately fire someone, right, acting before assessing, or we implement
these draconian new policies that paralyze the company, which violates the least restrictive
option rule.
Wow.
Yeah.
That happens all the time.
Taking a breath to assess the actual damage, finding the solution that causes the least
disruption while maintaining safety, documenting your process and bringing in an outside perspective,
that framework is completely universal.
So let's look at how those four pillars apply to the most immediate, severe crisis covered
in our notes, which is acute suicide risk.
We are talking about a scenario where the stakes literally cannot be higher.
Right.
And this is where that first rule assessed before you act becomes a strict non-negotiable
sequence.
You don't just ask a broad question like, are you okay?
And jump to conclusions.
You assess in a very specific order.
Exactly.
First is ideation.
Is the thought of suicide actually there?
If it is, you move to plan.
Is there a specific plan in place?
Then intent, do they actually mean to act on this plan?
Ideation, plan, intent, what's next?
Next is access.
Do they have the means to carry out the plan?
And finally, protective factors.
What is pulling them toward living?
So it's ideation, plan, intent, access, protective factors.
Walk us through why that specific staircase of assessment is so critical.
Why can't a professional just jump straight to asking about access to weapons?
Because the level of restriction you apply to a person's life depends entirely on where
they fall on those stairs.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Right.
So if there is no ideation, you don't interrogate them about a plan.
But if there is a plan, you must assess access immediately.
Because the risk level changes completely.
Exactly.
A client who has a detailed plan to use a firearm requires a totally different, highly
restrictive emergency response if they actually own one versus if they don't.
And professionals use a specific tool for this, right?
Yeah.
It's mentioned in the source, the Columbia Suicide Severity Rating Scale, or CSSRS.
Based on where a person lands on that scale, the interventions stack up accordingly.
Now, the notes point out a trap here regarding how professionals intervene.
And I'm going to push back on this a bit because it seems totally counterintuitive.
Oh, the no suicide contract.
Yes.
The material says, having a client sign a no suicide contract is a trap and an incorrect
intervention.
But in the corporate or legal world, signing a contract creates heavy psychological accountability.
Sure.
It feels very official.
Right.
So getting someone to physically sign a promise to stay safe, doesn't that create a vital
psychological hurdle that stops them from acting?
Why wouldn't we want that?
If we connect this to the bigger picture, the flaw in that corporate logic becomes
really obvious.
Agony doesn't obey contracts.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
No suicide contracts are not evidence-based because they're essentially asking someone
in immense unbearable psychological pain to just promise not to feel that way.
Or to suppress the only escape route their brain can currently see.
Precisely.
A contract might make the professional feel legally protected or give the illusion of
control, but it does not equip the client with any actual tools to survive a dark night.
It's basically demanding a result without providing a method.
Exactly.
Instead, the correct evidence-based intervention is collaborative safety planning.
How is that different from a contract?
A safety plan is a written document, sure, but the client helps build it.
It outlines their personal internal warning signs, specific coping strategies they agree
they can use, and exactly who they can call when things get dark.
So it's an actionable toolkit, not a legalistic promise.
Right.
It's paired with means-restriction counseling, which focuses on the practical side working
with the client or their family to temporarily remove access to lethal means, like locking
up medications or firearms.
So if you're looking at a list of options for how to help someone in crisis, the contract
for safety is a total mirage.
The other trap the notes highlight is the overreaction trap.
And this directly violates our second pillar, choosing the least restrictive option.
The human psychology trap here is immediately hospitalizing someone who merely expresses
a passing thought of suicide, but who has no plan and no intent.
Which feels like it would be a common reflex.
It is, because people panic.
But taking away someone's freedom by hospitalizing them against their will is the most restrictive
option possible in mental health.
So if you jump to that extreme without walking those assessment stairs, you're reacting
out of your own fear.
You're reacting out of anxiety and fear of liability, not clinical protocol.
We see this overreaction trap everywhere, right?
Back to that corporate analogy.
An employee makes a minor passing error and a panicked manager immediately fires them.
The most restrictive option.
Exactly.
Instead of putting them on a performance plan or just having a conversation, the manager
is reacting to their own anxiety about the project failing, completely bypassing the
assessment phase.
It's all about fighting the urge to let fear dictate the response.
Which brings us to a phenomenon where fear and panic are almost guaranteed human reactions.
Non-suicidal self-injury or NSSI.
Yeah.
This is a tough one.
We've just established that suicidal ideation is about the intent to end life.
But what happens when you encounter severe self-harm, where the intent is actually the
exact opposite?
We are talking about individuals using harmful behaviors as a desperate attempt to cope with
staying alive.
Yes.
The crucial distinction here is right in the name, non-suicidal.
This is self-harm without the intent to die.
So what is it about?
It is almost always a mechanism for regulating emotion that has become completely unbearable.
It provides this intense physical sensation that momentarily overrides or releases psychological
agony.
So the foundational rule is that you do not automatically treat it as a suicide attempt?
Correct.
I imagine human nature works heavily against us here.
I mean, the site of self-harm triggers intense alarm bells for parents, friends, even novice
professionals.
Absolutely.
It's terrifying to see.
I have two incorrect reactions people usually have, and I realize they are actually just
two sides of the same fearful coin.
On one side, you panic and auto-hospitalize every single instance as if it were a suicide
attempt.
And on the other side, the behavior makes you so uncomfortable that you dismiss it entirely,
just writing it off as attention-seeking.
Both of those reactions completely miss the function of the behavior.
How so?
Well, if you hospitalize, you are over-restricting and punishing a coping mechanism without
replacing it.
If you dismiss it as attention-seeking, you are invalidating deep pain and missing the
chance to intervene.
So what is the correct approach?
The correct approach is to conduct a functional assessment.
You are systematically asking, what psychological need is this physical behavior meeting for
this person right now?
Okay, so once you assist the function, say they are doing it to numb a feeling of overwhelming
panic, what is the actual intervention?
The notes mention pairing that insight with DBT skills, dialectical behavior therapy, specifically
something called distress tolerance.
But what does that actually look like in practice?
Distress tolerance is about giving the brain an intense sensory experience that resets the
nervous system, but without causing tissue damage.
So instead of self-harming to release emotional pressure, distress tolerance teaches a person
to say, hold an ice cube tightly in their hand until it melts, or to plunge their
face into a bowl of freezing cold water.
Really?
Freezing water?
Yeah.
The intense shock of the cold forces the mammalian dive reflex to kick in, which physically slows
down the heart rate and cuts through the emotional static.
You are giving them a new, safer way to meet that underlying need for intense physical
grounding.
You assess the function and you build the skill.
You build the skill instead of just locking them in a room or ignoring them.
That makes so much sense.
It really does.
Now, let's shift gears from specific physical self-harm to a broader kind of crisis.
The notes refer to this as general psychological decompensation.
Yeah.
Decompensation is essentially what happens when a person's mental scaffolding just starts
collapsing.
What does that look like?
They might be experiencing severe delusions, manic episodes, or just a total inability to
care for their basic daily needs.
The overarching question here is about the tying of therapy during an acute state.
Here's where it gets really interesting because the source material highlights another brilliant
trap here.
Yes.
The timing trap.
Exactly.
The most therapeutic sounding answer on a licensing exam, doing deep insight work, exploring root
causes or processing childhood trauma is actually the most dangerous, wrong answer you could
choose during an active crisis.
It is incredibly tempting to choose that path though.
As a professional or even as a friend, you want to get to the root of the problem.
You want to heal the core wound.
Naturally.
But doing deep psychological processing while someone's mental scaffolding is actively falling
apart is terrible timing.
During an acute mental health crisis, your order of operations is rigid.
Or just.
Stabilize the immediate symptoms, assess physical safety, and determine the least restrictive
level of care to keep them fed, sheltered, and safe.
Crisis work is inherently focused only on the present moment.
I was thinking about it using a mechanical analogy.
You wouldn't try to teach someone how to rebuild a carburetor while their car engine is actively
on fire.
That is exactly right.
You don't stand there explaining the nuances of the fuel air mixture while the flames
are melting the dashboard.
You stabilize the situation.
You put out the fire first.
Break the fire.
Once the car is cooled down and towed to a safe garage, then you can pop the hood
and do the deep diagnostic work.
Because deep trauma work can be incredibly destabilizing on its own.
It requires bringing up painful memories and dismantling old defenses.
Which takes energy they don't have right now.
If a person is already in an acute crisis, digging into their childhood trauma is quite
literally throwing gasoline on that engine fire.
That work comes much later when the person is steady, has a strong support system, and
actually has the emotional capacity to process the pain.
Stabilize first.
Safety next.
And this applies perfectly to our personal lives too.
If you and your partner are in the middle of a screaming match in the driveway and you're
both completely emotionally flooded, that is not the time to do a deep root cause analysis
of your marriage dynamics.
Absolutely not.
You stabilize.
You take a walk.
You cool the engine down before you open the hood.
Exactly the same principle.
Now, up until now, the danger we've been discussing has been entirely internal directed
at the self or manifesting as personal decompensation.
But the crisis framework fundamentally changes when the threat is directed outward.
This is where the notes introduce a massive clash between two fundamental ethical principles,
keeping the public safe versus maintaining strict client confidentiality.
Yes.
We are entering the realm of homicidal ideation and threat assessment.
This revolves around a famous legal and ethical doctrine known as the duty to warn and protect,
most commonly referred to as the Tarasoff Principle.
The Tarasoff Principle.
Okay.
This dictates that when there is an identifiable potential victim and a serious imminent threat
of harm, the professional's duty to protect human life completely overrides the duty to
maintain client confidentiality.
Meaning they have to break trust.
This means taking drastic steps, like warning the intended victim directly and notifying
law enforcement.
So what does this all mean for privacy in a therapist's office?
How do you distinguish between someone just blowing off steam, someone storming into
a session and yelling, I am so mad I could kill my boss right now, and a genuine Tarasoff
situation?
Right.
That's the big dilemma.
Does confidentiality just vanish the second a client expresses anger?
This raises an important question, and it is the exact threshold that licensing exams
and real world lawsuits scrutinize endlessly.
Confidentiality does not vanish easily because privacy is the bedrock of therapy.
Right.
If clients think they will be arrested for expressing dark thoughts, they'll just stop
talking.
And therapy stops working.
So the assessment criteria to breach confidentiality are incredibly rigorous.
You must assess for specificity, target, means, intent, and history.
Walk us through those criteria, specificity and target, meaning they have to name a specific
person.
Yes.
Vague, generalized anger with no identifiable target does not warrant breaching confidentiality.
Right.
Saying, you know, I hate everyone at my company and I want to watch the building
burn is concerning.
But if there is no specific target and no concrete plan, it doesn't trigger Tarasoff
in most jurisdictions.
So just venting about hating your boss, without a serious intent or a realistic plan to acquire
a weapon, is not a duty to warn?
No.
You do not shatter a client's privacy just because they are venting safely in a room.
But on the flip side, you can't be paralyzed by the fear of breaking confidentiality
if the threat is genuinely real.
Exactly.
You do not stay silent when there is a specific imminent threat to a specific
identifiable person and the client has the means to carry it out.
It is a razor thin threshold.
It sounds like you can fail in two very different ways.
You can.
You can fail by breaking confidentiality too early out of an overabundance of caution
over mere venting, which destroys the therapeutic relationship.
Or you can fail by waiting too long when the danger is real and present, which can literally
cost a life.
And because that threshold is so incredibly thin and the stakes are so unimaginably high,
that brings us right back to our fourth unbreakable pillar from the very beginning of this deep
dive consult.
Consult.
Always.
The notes heavily emphasize that consulting state law and consulting a clinical supervisor
is almost always part of the correct protocol in a Tarasoff situation.
Because the exact legal requirements for the duty to warn vary significantly from
state to state and the psychological nuances are immense.
You shouldn't do it alone.
No single practitioner should be making that call in a vacuum.
You assess the threat.
You document every single step of your thought process to show you acted reasonably, and
you consult with experts.
It is a closed loop system designed to protect everyone involved, the client, the public,
and the professional making the call.
As we synthesize all of this, I want to bring this directly back to you listening
right now.
Going through this rigorous framework assess before acting, find the least restrictive option,
document everything, and consult when unsure.
It doesn't just give you a window into how medical and therapeutic professionals operate.
It trains your brain.
It trains your brain to function differently under pressure.
It teaches you to pause.
It forces you to systematically assess the function of a crisis rather than just reacting
to the scary symptoms.
Which we all tend to do.
Whether you are managing a crisis at work, dealing with an emotionally flooded teenager,
or navigating a massive life transition, acting methodically rather than reacting
out of fear, is the ultimate antidote to panic.
Before we finish, I really want to leave you with something to consider.
Something that builds on all these rules but looks toward the very near future.
Okay, what is it?
As we move into an era where AI chatbots and algorithmic crisis text lines are increasingly
being used to triage human mental health, we face a massive dilemma.
How do you code a nuanced concept like least restrictive care into a machine?
Oh wow.
Yeah, how does a large language model understand the difference between emotional
venting and a concrete threat?
Exactly.
How will an AI learn to perfectly distinguish between a frustrated, dramatic teenager, harmlessly
venting about their life using hyperbolic language, and a true, imminent pterosoph threat?
Because human practitioners rely on decades of clinical intuition.
Right.
Body language, tone of voice, and deep functional assessments to walk that razor thin line.
If an algorithm is designed to prioritize liability and safety above all else, will it just
automatically trigger a police response at a coded caution every time someone uses the
word kill in a chat?
And if it does, how many people's privacy and autonomy will be shattered by an overreacting
machine?
It is a looming, massive question for the future of automated mental health care.
That is a fascinating thought to leave on because at the end of the day, as much as
we might want human behavior to be like engineering, as much as we want a clean x-ray that points
to a simple broken bone, the reality is that the human mind is infinitely complex.
It is absolutely is.
We are navigating murky waters, and the only way through is with a compass built on patience,
thorough assessment, and a deep, abiding respect for human autonomy.
Automatic beats clever every single time.
Keep going.
You've got this.
Until next time.